RICHARD CUMMINS: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for coming today.
As part of Black
Googler Network,
my name is Richard Cummins.
This is our first collaboration
with Talks at Google.
We're very welcome and thankful
for Remi Kapo coming in today
and speaking during
Black History
Month about his
new book and also
an introduction to
his life as well.
So big round of
applause for Remi.
Thanks for being here.
[APPLAUSE]
REMI KAPO: First of
all, let's start up
by thanking Google for
inviting me to hold this talk.
It's not usual for us in the
business of writing to actually
start a book off this way.
This is certainly new.
Let me start off by telling
you a little bit about myself.
Now, I came to England
in 1953 when I was seven.
I went to boarding school.
I was at that boarding school
about three or four or five
years.
And I ended up in
a children's home
for the next five, six
years, Beechholme Residential
Home in Banstead, Surrey.
And from there I went on
to become a cadet officer,
because I needed to
get away from England.
I needed to get
away from the shore.
I needed to get away from
everything I'd known before.
And the best thing I could
think of doing was going to sea.
So I was a cadet officer in a
nautical college, King Edwards.
After a year, I went there to
do three and a half years at sea
with British-India Steam
Navigation Company.
And I came ashore and took
my second mate's certificate.
So I became a navigation
officer after that,
which meant I was one of
the first black navigation
officers we had in England.
And it's quite
interesting actually,
because from being a cadet
officer being kicked around
to being a navigation officer
and holding executive authority
at a very young age meant that
all the things that people had
done to you, like seamen
had treated you badly,
they regretted it, because you
now had executive authority.
I was given my
first 12-man watch.
So it's eight hours off,
four hours on the bridge.
And that time these 12
men were presented to me.
And the captain noticed
there's two of them who
were exceptionally nervous,
because this was going
to be the officer of the watch.
And he said, Mr. Kapo, do
you know those two men?
When they'd gone.
I said, yes.
They said, Gave you a
hard time, did they?
I said, yes.
He said, Can I give
you a piece of advice?
I thought, no, I didn't
want a piece of advice.
I wanted to get my own back.
And then he said,
Let me give you
a piece of advice-- do
nothing, say nothing,
be very nice to them, treat
them with great kindness.
He said, because
all the time you're
the officer of the watch,
you have executive authority,
and you can make their life
miserable, which I could do.
At the end of that
three-month voyage, which
was from West India dock
all the way down to set
port in Nigeria and back,
they ran off the ship.
Thank you, Mr. Kapo.
That was a wonderful voyage.
We're signing back on.
And that was the
first time I learned
how not to use power
over people and how
to learn to understand
what power actually looked
like and felt like.
Anyway, let me move on.
I went from there.
I came ashore.
I started writing for
the "New Statesman."
From there I went to
Tim's Television, ATV.
Then I became the
director of The Roundhouse
in Chalk Farm for seven years.
And from there I then
decided to leave all that
and write a trilogy.
Now, this is where it
becomes interesting.
I thought, writing the trilogy--
but I'd never written
a book before.
Because I remember the next day
I phoned up some of my friends
who all had been great
authors, because I was living
in North London, wasn't it?
The intellectual
enclave in North London
where everybody, all the
writers and journalists, lived.
But, Remi, you just announced
you're going for 10 years
to write a trilogy.
I said, yes.
But didn't you know--
I said, well, I've
never written a trilogy.
I've never written a
novel for God's sake.
I've written a book, which
was a book called "The Savage
Culture."
That was a book
about life in Britain
as a black man on the
streets of Britain
and what had happened to me.
But I had never written a novel,
which was very, very different.
He said, well, I can't
really teach you.
And I realized why he couldn't.
A, they couldn't teach
me very much about this.
I wanted to write about slavery.
I wanted to write a story,
which started in 1600,
with a Nigerian family--
Yoruba family, some Yoruba--
and an English family,
landed gentry Catholics
from Yorkshire.
Now, what happened
to these two families
over from 1600 to 1966-- it
was almost a 400-year period.
And I thought, well, let
me read about slavery.
Now, I could find many
things about slavery
to do with abolition, but the
actual issue of slavery itself,
the actual mechanisms,
how slavery was used,
how slavery worked, the
business of slavery,
I couldn't find anywhere,
hardly anywhere.
Why?
It's almost as if
somebody in this rush
to write about abolition,
which was the nice end
of the wedge, nobody--
the unpleasant end,
which it would have been
unpleasant for black and white.
That was left behind.
That was kind of left out.
Nobody wanted to deal with that.
Therefore, I couldn't
find almost anything
to do with the
business of slavery.
So I realized what
I'd have to do.
I'd have to write
one, first of all,
before I could write the novel.
I'd have to write
the history book.
And that's what I set out to do.
Now, what else did I want to do?
I wanted to write a book that
was going to captivate and hold
both black and white
readers, because I noticed
that the whole issue
of slavery we had,
it made some people feel
guilty, some people angry.
Some people just didn't want
to read about it, deal with it.
But for me, it was
very, very important,
because inside some of the
worst catastrophes in the world,
you'll always find
a human compassion.
You will always find contact
between human beings.
I had a friend of mine,
Yehuda Segal, Jewish,
met his wife in Dachau
in the second World War.
And one of the questions
I asked him is,
was there not but one
German who took compassion
as to the way you
were being treated?
Because it was horrific what
they were going through.
He said, yes, we did.
We depended on some of the
Germans, because some of them
couldn't take it, couldn't
accept what was going on.
Well, equally was what
went on with slavery.
So I started looking
at the issue of slavery
even more closely.
When I looked closer,
I began to realize
that what we were talking
about was a minority of people,
both in the West African
coast and in Britain,
conducted slavery, owned the
slaves, owned the plantations.
And therefore, there
also from that minority
came the educated--
the educated minority-- who
also were going to be the ones
to write the story.
Well, obviously, those who
are going to write the story
were also going to--
a very human thing--
but we don't really
want to put this bit in,
because that's a bit unpleasant.
And so is this bit.
So it started
picking and choosing.
Now, if we were going to
learn anything about slavery,
we need to know a whole lot.
We are talking about an era
when the slave trade began,
where the working
class of Britain
was just as much enslaved
as the black people.
We were talking about an era
when the educated minority were
the upper middle class
and the aristocracy
and the landed gentry.
We're talking about
an era that they were
the ones who owned the slaves.
So we're talking about an
era that this mass had almost
nothing to do with slavery.
And yet when my people
arrived in Britain,
we looked around,
right across Britain,
we were all convinced that every
white family had an involvement
with slavery, which isn't true.
We'd lived with that.
I'd lived with that until
I began looking closely
into what slavery was about.
And the closer I
looked, the more
I realized slavery in England
was conducted by a minority,
was hand and hand
with the minority
of the establishment of the
rich and the wealthy on the West
African coast.
In other words, the
masses of both coasts
had virtually nothing
to do with it.
That made me really
interested, because I realized
that what we were talking about
when we're talk about slavery--
we're talking about a story
that should interest everybody
because we're both involved.
And therefore, I found
the very, very things
that I needed to
say, the very things
that I needed to portray
in the people themselves.
So there were people
who helped the slaves.
Of course there were.
There's one story, which
was really quite important.
It was the issue of, I
think, June 6, 1772, which is
called the Mansfield decision.
James Somerset escaped
from an American ship--
I think, from Rotherhithe.
He was passed
through safe houses,
through working class areas, to
the hands of the abolitionists,
like Granville Sharp
and Thomas Clarkson,
who decided at that time
here we have this man is--
why should-- he's escaped.
He should no longer be a slave.
He's now in England.
So what they were trying to say
is when somebody is over here,
they were no longer a slave.
But that needed to be
tested in the king's bench.
And that's when it was tested.
Over a period of six months,
Lord Mansfield prevaricated,
went this way and that way.
Because here was an
issue of his class
that's going to affect
people of his class.
That's also something
that's going to affect
all those people out there.
So what did he do?
By June, he decided to
free James Somerset.
Now, what was interesting
about that is this--
they needed about
150, 200 guineas
If you imagine 1722 what
200 guineas would be now.
We'd be talking an
awful lot of money.
Where did that money come from?
It came from working class
people, mainly white people,
collecting pennies and
farthings in these pubs
and establishments and
the cafes equivalent
and festivals all over
England, especially
in London, just
so that they could
get this one black man free.
And that's what made me realize
that-- my goodness, if we are
going to talk about
slavery anymore,
we needed to have stories that
actually we were attracted to.
We needed to read.
We need to understand.
Because through it,
we begin to understand
what England is really about.
Well, what England--
who England belongs to.
It belongs to all of us.
Because we've all
had something to do
with that whole issue of
slavery, which, by the way,
also basically
supported the finances
in this country, most of
the great houses, sugar.
All these huge
finance establishments
were built on the
back of slavery.
That doesn't mean that I
want people to feel guilty.
That's the one thing
we don't want anymore.
We need to get rid
of the guilt. We
need to get rid of the anger.
We need to replace it
with understanding.
So I thought the best way to do
it was to write the story, not
a history book for the
people, but to write
a story about people.
To write a novel that people--
a novel that people
could understand
how the humanity
of people comes out
when they see what activities
they are led to perform just
to free somebody else.
Just to say, I
support this person.
They respected the
color of his skin.
And that's what
we've always had.
We have always had
that in England,
but you wouldn't
think so though.
If you look outside
today, when you
think of the
difficulties we have
with the whole
issue of race, you
would not think for
a moment that there
was that commonality.
There was that community.
There was that spirit
that actually brought
black and white people
together in the 18th century
to free one black man--
quite extraordinary.
And that was one
of the reasons why
I wanted to write this
whole story about slavery.
Not one that was that to make
you angry, because I've had
enough of stories
that made you angry.
There's people that
make films that--
you've seen the whites
come in, and you walk out
of it feeling guilty.
Why?
They had nothing to do it.
There's nobody in
this room today
who was either a slave
owner or a slave.
And if there's anybody
in this room today
who came from a family where
they made money from it,
it's still not their
responsibility.
We've had enough of that.
That's what's actually held
us back as a people the fact
that people still feel guilty
and angry about slavery when,
in fact, this is something
that's affected us
detrimentally as a nation.
And so I think
it's about time we
put the whole issue of slavery
on a different footing,
on the footing of novels.
Because through those novels,
through those stories,
through the activities of
people in these stories,
we begin to understand
how people have actually
stood for each other.
Now, why hadn't this issue of
slavery been written about?
Well, until about
the 20th century,
I don't think
there's much written
about the history
of women, was there?
Until about 1938, when AR
Morton wrote "A People's History
of England," I don't think
there'd been anything written
about the history of the working
class, the majority for God's
sake.
That was the majority,
and yet 1938-- so we
can only come to
the whole history
of women in the
early 20th century
and the issue of
the working class,
the history of
in the early 20th century.
That helps me to
certainly understand
why black people and
their relationships
have come so late.
Now, if you look today at
our diverse community now,
in my generation--
I'm 71-- we didn't talk
about diversity in 1953.
I don't think anybody knew
how to spell the word.
And if they did know
how to spell it,
I don't think they knew
what it actually meant.
Now you look around
Google, you look
around some of the
companies today,
you look around at
the young generation.
When we left school, all the
black ones went this way.
All the white ones
went that way.
When my children left school--
one of them is in
the room today--
black, white, green,
yellow, pink went that way.
Same thing went that way.
In other words, they
have a commonality.
They had had a community.
They had understood diversity.
They lived with that.
And they had learned
from us that we
don't want to make the
mistakes your generation made,
my generation.
Actually, my generation
and my parents' generation
actually stabilized Britain
after the second World War
and then held it back
towards the '60s.
We held it back
because we couldn't
find any kind of commonality.
We couldn't find a way through
the difficulties of race.
We could not find any community.
My generation failed
England because of that.
Now when I look around
my children's generation,
they're doing a
lot better then us.
They've still got
a long way to go,
but they're doing a
lot better than we did.
And I think that's the
direction Britain is on.
When I look at even this
audience today, my god,
I've got every
color in the world,
which I think is fantastic.
And you're sitting
where you want to sit.
Oh, no, in my generation,
the black ones
sat together, the white
ones sat together.
The very first time
I walked into Google,
I was stunned by
the array of colors,
the array of disinterest
as to who was who.
We could not find a community
of understanding, my generation.
And in that way, we
were the worst ones
to actually lead Britain
into the new century--
absolutely-- and that we
are actually taking now--
we're being led by our kids.
And that's a good thing, because
at least our children are not
trying to hold the country back.
They're actually trying
to find a way through.
Now, that to me is important.
That's why it was
important for these--
I've got two books so far.
"Reap the Forgotten
Harvest" is the first one.
"Torrents of Fire"
is the second.
And there's a third
one to come out.
That will make the total
box set, should we say,
of this trilogy, because I
wanted to go to the 1960s.
Why?
I wanted to come not
too close to where
we are now but close enough
that I could actually say,
this is not just that we failed
in a way but how we failed.
And that it would help the
next generation not commit
the kind of mistakes we made.
But you have to have slavery,
not as a fearful thing,
which is what we had.
You notice it today.
On my Facebook page-- my son
was running my Facebook page,
and there's a lot of
people writing it,
but we were the first
ones to abolish it.
The issue we're talking
about was slavery.
Who did what with whom?
Who supported whom?
I mean, how many
stories must there be?
My editor, Dr. Jill
Sudbury, she has
a family where, in
the 1720s, her family
were helping a slave get a job.
And they've got that history.
So you can imagine
the history of slavery
has yet to be written.
That's what we need to do.
We need to write it.
Now, I am just one person.
The next generation will
write it even better.
And they'll have even more.
Why?
Because the families--
personal stories
will come from
different families.
And the government
will probably release
even more documentation.
For instance, they released
a document to-- well,
more than one set of documents--
when the slave trade
was ended in 1833, '34.
In order to end it, the slave
owners said, we will lose out.
So the slave owners were paid.
The government
basically used 40%
of the gross domestic product
to buy the lives of the slaves,
to buy the slaves
of the slave owners.
But nobody ever thought
that these files would ever
come out.
So anyway, it's all put
down, and they were all
shoved in the treasury,
disappeared into the treasury.
One day, the government
released those files to--
guess who?
University College
London who immediately
went through them properly
and documented them,
up they went into the internet.
And we know once it
gets into the internet,
it gets everywhere.
Well, lots of people
started, yeah,
but we've got no money left.
The fact of the matter is that
a lot of the families who owned
slaves then are still here now.
They're not guilty.
They should not need to
have to stand up to say--
and Richard Dawkins
did not need to say,
well, we've got
none of the money.
It was all spent
a long time ago.
He shouldn't have
needed to say that.
David Cameron, whose
ancestors also owned slaves,
didn't need to excuse
himself, right?
Because he didn't do it.
And that's what
I'm trying to say
is that what has happened
yesterday happened yesterday.
We don't want the
families of the great
and the good or
the landed gentry.
We don't need them
to come and say,
we've got no money
left yet but--
we know the money is there.
We don't even need England
to say our major cities
like Liverpool,
Bristol, and London were
built on the back of slavery.
We don't need any
excuses for that.
We just need to
know the history.
We don't need to know
who did what to whom.
But we need to know mostly
how it supported this, that,
and the other, and how
these industries were
built over a period
of time, and how
money was made from slavery.
Because it's no good saying,
what are the black people
doing here?
I think they've already
paid with their bodies.
And I think that there's an
awful lot of white people
who supported them, who
not only supported them,
who married them.
When you think of
today, in Britain,
we have 10% of our
nation is now what?
Mixed race.
My own children-- I'm very
proud to say-- my children
are mixed race.
And I'm very proud of that.
They're very clever.
And, of course, every
father says that.
But I really mean it.
And the fact of the matter is
that they represent both of us.
What are we going to do?
We're going to attack them
because they're mixed race?
They're part of us.
And there's a bridge between us.
And therefore, what I needed
to say, what I needed to do
was to write something
that became like a bridge.
So the books I've written
are for black and white.
I wanted to keep both eyes
of black and white people
on the same page
all the way through
without feeling they are
being offended in anyway.
But you don't need
to be offended.
That's not what
slavery is about.
That's not what the
whole story is about.
The story is about something
that should unite us today
not divide us.
And yet it is still dividing us.
It's dividing us because
we don't understand it.
We fear it.
And what you fear can
certainly divide you.
And slavery is something
we shouldn't fear any more
than men should fear the fact
that women have been set back
and that women need to
have one huge step forward.
Absolutely.
We shouldn't fear that.
That should be something
we should warm to simply
because it needs to be done.
And we need to understand
the issues of--
certainly, our children
need to understand this--
that their mixed race status
shouldn't set them back
in any way whatsoever.
They're virtues.
It gives them advantage.
It should give them an even
bigger advantage then I have.
And I didn't have that
in the advantages.
But the fact of the matter
is that our children
should have the
advantages I never had,
both of them, black and white.
This division of black
and white has been really
promulgated very much by
the whole issue of slavery.
And I'm saying to you
today that until we
begin to realize that slavery
is something we control,
it doesn't control
us, we don't fear it.
We don't need to fear it.
We need people who used
slavery as a cudgel
to bash each other with, and
that's not going to happen.
That's not going happen.
That's why I spent two
years traveling just
along the West African
coast, photographing
the entire British
efforts of the forts
and factories of the slave
trade, around the Caribbean,
and all over England.
That was two years traveling.
Then I did two years in the
British Library researching
as much as I could
on what was left.
And then I did 10
years writing just
to get the whole issue
of slavery on a footing
that I could understand.
Once I could understand it, once
I realized what it was about,
once I realized
where it was going,
then I was able to
say to myself, right,
I'm not in control
of this issue.
And I'm going to be
the one who's going
to say next where it goes to.
And where it goes to is this--
that slavery has divided this
country for far too long,
and that slavery is something
that only divides it
because we don't understand it.
Slavery is something that was
an issue that people used to--
it's a great pub talk
to wind people up with.
I mean, you see people
getting in pubs.
You enslaved us.
Yes, but we were the
ones who freed you first.
Don't think that matters.
It's irrelevant actually.
It's totally irrelevant.
What is more relevant is
that something happened.
What?
And let's get this clear.
In a country which is
so divided by class,
the biggest division of all--
class is like the elephant
infant in the room in England.
Class is the one
that everybody fears.
Now, in a country that's
so divided by class
that when I tell you
a lot of the working
class of this country
behaved then as they do now.
When the first slaves got
their first houses and places
to live in the
east end of London
and different parts of England,
where do you think they lived?
They lived in Lord
so-and-so's house?
No.
Working class houses.
When our people arrived in this
country in the '40s and '50s,
where did we live?
Working class houses.
That's where we've always
had our friendships.
That's where we've
always had our meets.
always had unification.
That's who we had children with.
And because of that
that's why the working
class in this country
has been the greatest
friends of black people through
the centuries and still are.
And when you go to
your working class pub,
you hear, but we freed you.
And they've got nothing
to do-- they didn't even
know anything from slavery.
And that's really, really
the meat of something
that didn't exist.
It didn't exist.
And what did exist is
that a class above them
perpetrated it.
There's no need to hate them,
because we can't change that.
What we can do is understand it.
And therefore, in
writing what I did,
I wrote it to help
understanding,
to bring people together, to
bring understanding together,
not to divide.
I didn't write it to create
any more kind of division
that we already have.
We have enough division.
We have racial division
in this country
that hasn't changed that much.
But it's changing because
the next generation suddenly
got tired of the lack of unity.
They got tired of
doing the same thing.
We couldn't find
any understanding.
We could not find
any understanding
between us, my generation.
And therefore, and I can see
that everybody in this room,
I should imagine,
younger than me,
apart from that one over there.
And he, in particular,
would understand this
because we went through
very similar things.
Now if, for instance, we are now
going to find the way forward,
what we need to do,
I think, is to accept
that holding back the next
generation of black writers
or women writers or
working class writers
is not going to solve anything.
We need to hear from them.
We need to read what
they have to say.
We also need to find out that
the issue we're talking about
is probably one of the
most exciting issues
that I've come across in
the time I've been here.
Why exciting?
Because of the things
people did for each other.
Wow!
I was stunned by this stuff I
found out, what people actually
did, what people were
prepared to do for each other.
So I spent some of my
best years of my life
putting that down and writing
it into the form of a story that
wasn't untrue.
It was perfectly true.
I just happened to
put it into a novel.
Now, it's easier to write--
when I wrote my first
book, "Savage Culture,"
that was a factual book.
It was much easier to
write that than to write
a novel of 500 pages.
You've got to be
crazy to sit down
to want to write a
novel of 500 pages,
because it takes a lot more.
It takes a lot more out of you.
And I just think that--
I mean, the last
one was 400 pages.
And I thought, my god, that
really took a lot out of me.
I'll never do this again.
And next one is 500.
It's 100 pages longer.
I promise you the next one
won't be more than 650 pages.
I'll try and keep it short.
But the thing is
it's a big story.
It is a big issue.
And it is an issue that we
need more than one set of eyes.
I don't mind a white man
writing as a black character.
To write that book, I had
to write as black and white.
So what did I have to do?
I had to lose my blackness
intellectually, emotionally,
and you do.
Because one of the things--
the moment somebody
sits down and reads
your novel and feels
that, this is written by
a black person or white,
you're going to lose it.
You don't want to feel anything.
You really, really don't.
And to emotionally
lose yourself,
the thing you've known all your
life, the color of your skin,
and that black mentality,
because everything out
there reminds you every day--
you're black.
You're black.
And suddenly, one day, you
have to sit down in your study,
and you have to
lose that blackness.
I remember the first time I
wrote a scene where a slave was
going to be punished.
Here I was-- a white
person was going
to punish this black person.
What was I going to?
Hold, pull the punches?
No.
It took me at least six
months to get over it,
just to get over how to do it.
It took me about a year to
understand what I was doing.
But once I got into that,
I found that it was easier.
And it actually made it
easier for somebody to read,
because they weren't going
to have this thing be shoved
in their face all the time.
They weren't going to have
guilt or anger or dissension
or dissatisfaction.
They were not going to have
that be pushed into their face
all the time.
So you need to lose
your blackness.
Now, if you're going
to be a white man
writing or a white woman
writing as a black character,
there's nothing wrong with that.
We need to get past all of that.
We've had arguments
in this country.
There was almost like
an unwritten rule
in the '50s, '60s, and
'70s that you never wrote
as any other race but your own.
And if you wrote as any
other race, it was a cameo.
Now if you do 500
pages of something
to do with a story as big as
this, you have to be both.
You do have to be both.
Equally, I've had
women writers who've
written as men and very
successfully as well.
And it can be done, but
you have to do it simply
because we're not interested
in the color of your skin.
We're not interested in
your gender, so and so.
We're interested in the story.
And I don't want it
shoved in my face
how you feel about me as a
man or woman or this or that
or the other.
And that's what's essentially
important in writing this.
And that's what you've
got to get across.
Because if you ever
get into film material,
then it's got to be balanced.
It's that balance you've got to
find in yourself as a writer.
And that balance is
not easy to achieve.
It really, really isn't.
In fact, it's very
difficult to achieve,
but once you get the
understanding what
it is you know
what you're doing,
it makes it much easier, far
more interesting, and far more
useful for the reader, because
you're not asking the reader
to feel guilty.
You're not asking the
reader to feel angry.
I'm an African now.
What part did I play
in the slave trade?
What part did my people
play in the slave trade?
Well, we played part of
selling our own people
as well as being sold ourselves.
Now, my West Indian friends
were very angry about it
in the '60s.
My god, they feel
very angry about it.
And in feeling that
anger, we could never
get a conversation through
more than half an hour
before it exploded.
Now we're going to
get past all that.
We're going to get past that.
People have got
to understand you,
the white man, or you, the
black person, was never a slave.
You were never a slave owner.
You were just a person who
represents those colors.
That's all.
But you're nothing
more than that.
And the moment we begin to get
past that, we get into the era
where it becomes
interesting-- what happened?
So what I'm saying today that
Britain needs to get away
from the things we
know about abolition,
and we know all about that.
We need to know what happened
in this 400-year period
of history--
all the kinds of things.
So we need the shipping
records, the shipping companies,
like the Royal African Company,
East India Company, all those.
We need those records found.
We need to find out where
they were trading to.
I mean, I myself was fascinated
as to which shipping companies
would pick up from which
African ports along the West
African coasts, where'd they'd
bring them to England sometimes
or straight to the Caribbean.
Now, in England, we had what's
called the major ports--
London, Liverpool, and Bristol.
Then we had the minor
ports, myriads of them,
tiny little ones in Essex,
all around the coast, even
Rutherhithe.
And Gravesend was a minor port.
And these were the middle class.
One ship-- if we could do
a run down to West Africa,
take 300 slaves and move it
to there and sell them there,
we could make quite a killing.
Now, all of those port
authorities have records.
We need those records.
Everybody needs those records.
And this is what
I'm saying today.
That's why I've written
these three books.
And we need the records
of the slave trade
brought out so that we can
have the Englishmen of today,
Englishwomen of today,
whatever color, I don't care,
write the story about slavery.
And in writing the
story about slavery,
we have a much better idea
of what has gone on before us
and what has made us
the way we are today.
I think I'd better leave
it here to give you
some time to ask questions.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
RICHARD CUMMINS: We do
have time for questions.
AUDIENCE: Hello, Remi.
Thank you very much.
That was an amazing
speech and talk.
So thank you for
coming to Google.
I have a question.
I'm not sure if you're
aware, on Monday,
we actually had a doodle
on the home page of Google.
You know about this.
REMI KAPO: My family
showed it to me, yes.
Equiano.
AUDIENCE: I'm interested to
know what you think about that.
And also, I'm interested to
kind of ask you, as an African,
how did you feel about
seeing this doodle
on the homepage of Google.
REMI KAPO: Well,
myself, anything
that produces information
about yesterday
is, to me, to be applauded.
We shouldn't have waited
for Google to do it.
We should have been doing
this in our newspapers.
We should be doing it ourselves
in England a long time ago.
It seems that it's taken the
Americans to actually wake us
up and remind us that--
I mean, we've only
just remembered about--
somebody wrote-- David
Olusoga and "The Guardian"
wrote something about
that "Roots" is now
going to be remade.
Where is England's roots?
Well, England's roots
has always been here.
The trouble is we've
spent as much time
as we can avoiding
dealing with it,
while the Americans have
dealt with it, because they've
got no choice.
Their enslavement was
homemade, and they
can't get away from it.
Therefore, by
their making it, we
are quite happy to carry
on re-showing "Roots"
and re-showing "Roots" without
any white Englishmen or woman
or black Englishman or woman
being able to actually write
about what we've done.
And the BBC-- the
BBC of all people--
saying, it's time we
made a film about it.
The BBC will be shamed
into it in the end.
Why?
Because they don't know
how to actually recognize
English history
from English people.
And I think that here--
Olaudah Equiano is
a classic example.
Why hasn't the BBC
made a production
about Olaudah
Equiano, a big one?
Because through his life
and through his example,
there's so much I'm saying
today he said before me.
And I'm glad that Google has
bothered to go and do that,
because it's reminding
Britain all the time that we
have a responsibility
to this new generation.
And the responsibility we have
towards this new generation
is to give them all
the information-- more
information-- and
allow them to get
their hands on the controls.
Because we know
that with the hands
on the controls
of my generation,
it's not going anywhere.
And so, yeah, that's
a good question.
That really is a good question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Where do you think the
future lies for Black History
Month?
REMI KAPO: Well,
in effect, if we
follow its natural progression,
Black History Month will
eventually cease to
exist, because we'll
see more of our history as--
because our histories
didn't happen separately.
When you think in terms
of slave trade, by the way
we [AUDIO OUT] today,
the slave trade,
where there was black slaves,
and there was white people,
but there's no
relationship between.
It's that relationship
we need to find.
That relationship is
where history takes place.
That relationship
is also where we
need to remind people that
this history, as we call it,
is not history.
It's one way of
telling something.
Now, the history I
learned at school
was white history, mainly
monarchical, lords and ladies,
the establishment,
the big companies.
And I remember the
first history book
I read, I think by Trevelyan, in
'57, had a paragraph that big.
This was the whole slave
trade-- this 400-year period
of something that actually
bolstered Britain into a major
trading nation--
slavery-- was a few
lines, and they had
elicited, what, 10,000 slaves.
So I was trying to work out--
that young mind of mine
was trying to work out,
10,000 slaves every 400 years.
That's not very many.
And as the years went on, the
numbers grew and grew and grew.
Now, unless we unify
history, we will
have to keep Black History
Month to keep reminding people
that black history does exist
along with white history.
But we shouldn't need that.
We need our history
book re-written clearly.
And so we will celebrate
history together.
We might have a white
history day or black history
day, something like that.
I think Black History
Month is important.
And I think one has to
praise companies like Google
for even bothering to have it.
But I think I understand
why they have it,
because they see all
the people they employ
and the diversity of the
community they employ
to be such that they
have a responsibility
to their own staff.
Well, I think we have a
responsibility to Britain.
And I think we have a
responsibility to Britain,
and that's why when this
government, whichever
government it is, when they've
finished all their arguing
over Brexit and
everything else, and they
begin to realize that
there's also pressing issues
within the nation that
needs to be changed.
You can't have the same old
class system that we've had,
which keeps things going
along the same old ways
that we've had up till now.
And that's why
Black History Month
is something we should
be looking to get
rid of over a period of time.
Absolutely.
That's where its direction lies.
AUDIENCE: Question
about history.
So Britain had colonies all
across the world from Australia
to India to Egypt to whatnot.
So why did this happen only
from West Africa to America?
There could have been
slaves from, say, India.
It was a populous place.
They could have brought them
from there or from Egypt.
Is it forgotten history?
Or nothing happened that
way, or why was it this way?
REMI KAPO: I think it's a lot
to do with where you were.
In India, the whole concept
of colonial India was itself--
they called in a
jewel in the crown.
It has everything England
needed in position, in situ.
So the Indians, when
slaves [AUDIO OUT],,
they didn't need to
take them anywhere else.
They could enslave
them in India,
which is exactly what happened.
The Lodge, as we
called it, was not
a benign, nice kind of club.
It was a brutal club.
It really was.
I mean, the Indians tried to
get rid of the English twice.
There were two wars of
independence, not one.
And so, in a sense,
the Indians saw that,
and they also
realized that England
didn't need to
take them anywhere,
because they could enslave
them there, get everything
from there.
And the East India Company
was a classic example
and headed by people
like Lord Curzon, who
was a great colonist.
They had absolutely
everything in place.
Now, when it came
to West Africa,
they were talking about
what we needed to develop.
Why couldn't you just develop
the plantations in West Africa?
Well, it was a brutal
land, wasn't it?
I mean, they had diseases
they've never even heard of.
The West Africa, for instance,
was called the White Man's
Grave because of
all the diseases
that existed along there.
So taking them away from there
to somewhere which is far more
salubrious, which was far
less dangerous and far more
controllable, was far
better for the English.
Remember, it wasn't the
majority of Englishmen involved.
You're talking about a
small elite in England
who owned the shipping
companies, who
owned the plantations.
And what they were doing was
developing their plantations
with the sugar, they'd sell
it over here and sell it
around the world, make the
money, build their estates,
build the exchanges,
and basically build
London, Bristol, and
Liverpool, from which
everything else sprang from.
Now, having done that,
they did not need--
remember, they also had a
pressure of the working class
here.
And they were
keeping them at work
enslaved in the mill towns.
It was an enslaved
working class in England.
And so I understand
the establishment
in this country, why they don't
want to deal with the issue,
because it's a big issue.
It's a much bigger
issue than race
when it comes to class-- a much,
much bigger issue than race.
And it's also a
very dangerous one.
I myself try to avoid it.
I touch on it in my
books, but I think
I need to sit down
with other people
to work it through as to
how it can be portrayed,
because the controlling minority
will never have the greatest
interests of the
majority at heart.
And saying that, they've never
had the controlling interests
to better them in a sense.
Hence, charitable
companies came in.
They were the ones who
did the charitable works.
And the government
itself and the state
itself avoided all that.
I think it was
understandable why you never
need to move anybody
away from India,
you never needed to
move anybody to Africa.
Africa is far too
difficult. I mean,
have you seen the
size of Africa?
It takes in--
Russia, India, China, a
number of other nations,
all on one continent.
It's a huge continent,
and that was far too big.
But it's easier to take
them away from there
and develop in small
islands over there.
And what has it left?
It's left a rift between black
people of the same race who,
to the extent, treat
each other badly
because one was born
in the Caribbean
and one was born in Africa.
And yet they're the same race.
And that's something we
still have to deal with.
That's an issue I find
really tears at me.
Because when I met a West
Indian when I was young--
they don't do it so much
now, but we were young--
oh, you sold us.
Oh, my God.
Jesus Christ.
I don't have any money.
I mean, I don't have anything.
But the fact of the matter
is that that was very, very
uppermost in their minds.
Almost like somebody
said, they sold you.
Look at that.
They sold you.
That is an issue that
is also still with us.
So all the issues I'm talking
about are still here with us.
They're issues we
have to deal with.
And I try to deal
with that in here,
in this "Torrents of Fire."
I try to deal with the issues of
the difference between the West
Indians and the Africans.
There's no difference.
They are ours.
So when we start talking
about reparations--
and people do.
They talk about reparations.
And the first one they
say, Britain must pay.
Why only Britain?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
If we're looking at
reparations sensibly,
we'd be looking at every nation
in Europe that took part.
We'd look at the
establishment of every nation
in West Africa that was
involved as well, as well
as the Americas, and the Spanish
colonies in South America,
so on and so forth.
Now, if you look at
reparations that way,
you're talking about a
very small amount of money
to actually reparate the
Caribbean islands as nation
states.
And that's what
needs to be done,
but you cannot go for
Britain and leave that side
the Africans.
Oh, well, because
they've got problems.
No, no, no.
The fact of the matter is
that there are Africans today
who we have landed gentry today
whose estates are built up
on it.
We have whole areas
of our commerce today
that was started from slavery.
But we've got the
same in Africa.
And Africa needs to be
involved in that as well.
In other words, if you're
dealing with these issues,
include everybody.
Don't leave anybody out.
Because we have
serious things to deal
with when it comes to
the emotional differences
between Africans and
the West Indians.
There's no difference
between West Indians.
Every West Indian
I meet, I always
call them Yoruba, even
Sydney back there.
He says, I'm Nubian.
No, you're not.
You're Yoruba.
You're one of ours.
And the fact of the matter
is I'm very proud of that.
I really am proud of
that, because I recognize
all our brothers and sisters
in the Caribbean should
have rights to go to
any place in Africa.
If they don't know
where they're from,
they have a right
to go anywhere.
RICHARD CUMMINS: Time
for one more question.
REMI KAPO: OK.
AUDIENCE: There was a number
of articles in "The Guardian"
and in "New Statesman"
as well about removing
the historical statues
in Britain of people
who were involved in
slavery, like Cecil Rhodes,
but also, which was a
bit surprising to me,
Nelson who turns out
was a big defender
of slavery in the parliament.
What's your opinion about that?
REMI KAPO: My opinion
is very simple.
It's this.
Brushing away history
is difficult. Unwriting
a book is difficult. So
say a book was written,
like "Mein Kampf" was written.
Now, should we destroy it?
It should never
have been written.
be in the library.
No, it's been written.
It's in the library.
We should leave it there.
If Nelson was put there,
I haven't got a problem
with Nelson being there.
But I think, at the same time,
at the foot of Nelson's column
should be all the
other feelings he had,
all the other
things he felt like,
like some of the great
columnists who are supposed
to have been so wonderful and
done amazing things for India,
so on and so forth.
But we should also have
at the foot of them,
at the same time, a plaque that
says all the other things so
that that satisfies both
sides of the feelings
towards that individual.
RICHARD CUMMINS: A very
quick last question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
On the question of technology--
REMI KAPO: Technology.
AUDIENCE: Technology, yes,
and scientific developments
and how we may access those--
I'm thinking both in terms of
digitization and the ability
to search digitized records
and also DNA and the way
that we can now map through
our DNA our origins.
And perhaps you could just talk
about how these sorts of issues
affected not only our
own research for this,
but how this could
have an impact
for future generations
of researchers
on the subject of slavery?
REMI KAPO: Yes.
Well, that's a good question.
They're all good
questions actually,
but part of the issue of
not knowing is now to know.
So part of the thing of
the West Indian community,
say, in England, they
should always have a right.
All West Indian people
of West Indian background
should all have a fundamental
right for their DNA
to be assessed if they
wish and to find out
precisely where they're from.
Because knowing-- I
know my background,
and I know my Europe ancestors--
800, 900 years, we can
almost name everybody.
But that's because Yorubas were
very much an isolated people
in that sense and were
also conquerors by the way.
They were just as
colonized like the British.
Most people were.
And most of us all
had slaves as well.
But the thing is--
that's just one aspect
of it, for people
to know where they're from.
So since our nation was one
who moved themselves there,
there, and there, they
should have a right--
almost like state funds
should be paid for that.
Because of digitization, we are
able to access a whole amount
of other information.
We've got universities,
haven't we?
We have researchers.
We have bundles of
researchers and universities
who could be put to
use actually accessing
the records for us and
for the next generation
about the whole issue of
slavery and what part it played
and where the records,
what part they played,
and what they mean.
Now we've got--
I don't know how
many researchers
we have in universities around
Britain and how many of them
aren't being put to use.
Now, if they bother to go to
do all their PhDs and DPhils
and master's and
all that, surely we
should also be using
those same people
to actually access records
and for those records
to be published.
Now, one of the
ones that we've got
was the UCL ones, which
came from the treasury.
How many other departments of
government-- now, remember,
England is a very
secretive nation.
We got records dating back
to everywhere and every time.
Why don't we release the records
of the various government
departments dating
back to whenever so
that we can find out and use--
since we go to
these universities--
why don't we use some
of our researchers
to do something useful?
RICHARD CUMMINS: Thank
you very much, Remi Kapo.
REMI KAPO: Thank
you very, very much.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]